ohio republican mike turner ranking
republican on the intel committee sir
good morning to you and thanks for doing
our program good morning
what did you see
what did you find
we know bill just last week the
director of homeland security declared
that the border was secure so three of
us from the intelligence committee went
down to the border we met with the fbi
dea texas public uh security department
and and we can tell you not only is the
border not secure that in fact the
director is just absolutely lying but it
remains a significant national threat to
our country we saw evidence and spoke to
the officers there about the
unbelievable amount of criminal activity
drugs being smuggled humans being
smuggled the people who are crossing the
border many who are coming across the
border are not even from the western
hemisphere people flying into mexico and
then making it in in to our border and
across the border this represents an
absolute national security threat yeah
they're flying into monterey right and
hopping a ride that takes a couple hours
and then they make their move i mean
it's been going on for so long do you
believe
if republicans take the house or senator
both in november that this changes
or do you believe as long as joe biden
is president in the white house that
this will continue
well it certainly will make it very
difficult another thing that we learned
is that you know not only did the border
patrol agents say that the
border
wall works but that when the
administration stopped the wall there
are huge gaps from where the wall was
being constructed and even former areas
where there was fencing that was being
repaired they stopped those repairs now
congress can certainly assert itself on
funding for the wall and on uh funding
to protect the border
give the border patrol agents what they
need which is increase technology and
increase funding but absolutely uh this
is a policy that ends up at the white
house and the fact that the president uh
is uh you know failing to secure the
border while at the same time declaring
the american public that the border is
secure
is something that we're going to be
fighting against so you're saying though
that there is no end to this
i think you know clearly we need a
change in the white house uh ultimately
to affect all of the policies that are
necessary we certainly saw that under
the trump administration the beginning
of the construction of the wall the
remain in mexico policy of the pressure
on mexico to address these issues of the
long caravans that are headed toward the
united states but certainly congress can
have an impact the republicans if we
take back uh the house have the ability
both in funding and support for border
patrol agents i mean these guys are
doing an incredible job both the fbi di
dea and fbi we need to fund them give
them the technology and tools and
they'll catch even more and they'll
secure our border even okay all right
we'll see in time if you're right hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now